hey guys what's up we are back with
another video about guide you and
monsters in this video we shall focus on
the main villain the arch enemy and the
bane of Godzilla who is none other than
Ghidorah King Ghidorah the fictional
guide you will first appear in issue a
Honda's 1964 film Ghidorah the
three-headed monster although the name
of the character is officially
trademarked by Toho as King Ghidorah the
character was originally referred to as
Dedra in some English markets even
though King Ghidorah
design has remained largely consistent
throughout its appearances there have
been notable changes and appearances as
well as the types of versions that
differ greatly from the original design
its origin story has varied from being
an extraterrestrial planet killing
dragon a genetically engineered monster
from the future a garden monster of
ancient Japan a regard from another
dimension so anyway here's a list of ten
forms of Ghidorah which differ from each
other well they are a couple that look
quite similar so they are clubbed
together well some like those which are
younger forms which haven't evolved yet
are placed differently
number one the classic space monster
originally appearing in the 1964 movie
Ghidorah the three-headed monster he is
a golden dragon with two legs three hats
on long necks giant back like wings from
the back and two tails king odorous
multiple heads were inspired by Yamata
no Orochi an eight headed dragon from
japanese mythology King Ghidorah is an
alien dragon set to attack Venus under
his own power many thousands of years
ago wiping out the planets entire
civilization he later attacked earth but
was repelled by Earth's monsters so this
version of Ghidorah is a hundred metres
tall and weighs thirty thousand tons and
leaves on his first appearances the
version of Ghidorah is the most common
while having slight differences in
design although later versions bearing
the similar form different in height and
weight
number two desgidora des Ghidorah is a
Ghidorah created by Toho that first
appeared in a 1996 Toho film the rebirth
of Mothra desk odorous heads bear
resemblance to the gara whilst wings
bear
striking resemblance to destroyers he
also has many resemblances to Keyser
Ghidorah as they are both four-legged
and the first forms wingless des
Ghidorah can emit hell's flames from the
mouth of his middle head he spits lava
gout energy balls from the mouths of all
three of his heads and can unleash a
powerful shock wave released from all
over his body he can also send a red
electric surge truest bites other powers
include the ability to release hurricane
winds from his wings and he can fly at
speed of Mach 23 so millions of years
ago des Ghidorah first appeared on
planet mars destroying it and turning it
into a wasteland it then flew to Planet
Earth with the more intend to destroy it
it began attacking the planet but it was
met with waste with a revoked array is
called the Elias small human-like beings
said moths were to defeat him this guy
jus stands at a hundred meters tall and
weighs 75 thousand tons number three the
Guardian monster the Guardian monsters
is the collective term for three mighty
beasts that would arise to protect Japan
from a mighty force they appeared in
Godzilla Mothra and King Ghidorah the
giant monsters all-out attack one of the
monsters which was hailed as the god of
the sky was none other than Vidura
unlike all of his other films in
disappearance he was actually the good
guy this 1,000 year-old bright and shiny
dragon was hibernating inside his
crystal tome until he was awakened
following Godzilla's rampage originally
known as Yamata no Orochi a dragon with
eight heads he was slain and was
prophesized to Rhea wake and defend
Japan but as of the events of GMK ki
dhaara has only regrown back three of
his eight heads he was a small
incarnation of the three-headed dragon
standing only at 50 meters tall and
weighing only 20,000 tons as compared to
other forms which have crossed a hundred
thousand tons or more number four the
first form of monster eggs
monsta x was a bipedal creature with an
exoskeleton like armored skin he
possesses two small half skulls on his
shoulders and a long black four tail
most eggs has red eyes a skeletal face
and long spikes from the
his head unlike most of the zillions
other mind-controlled masters and final
walls monsta x displays true malice in
his battle with godzilla fighting to
viciously and relentlessly he seems to
take pleasure in causing godzilla pain
such as when he twists Godzilla's wrist
and suspends him into the air when he
holds Godzilla still for Jagan to slice
him with his chainsaws most extra to the
height of 120 meters and as a weight of
60,000 tons he appeared to be at par
with Godzilla in hand-to-hand combat as
well as the intensity of his power beams
which ended up like a Goku vs vegeta
duel number 5 Durant's door as a small
genetically-engineered guys you created
by Toho that first appeared in the 1991
Godzilla film Godzilla vs. King Ghidorah
they were genetically engineered to be
the perfect pets in a 23rd century
according to the Japanese novelization
of Godzilla vs. King Ghidorah the door
rats were engineered from genetic
material recovered from King G Doris
preserved corpse on Venus by the future
Ian's there were three of these door ads
brought from the future by the future
ins they were kept on the Futurist ship
mother and its sister ship kids first
being seen when amy takes the humans on
board they were taken back in time to
lagus island in 1944 where the future
UNS believe that the lated Castle Bravo
nuclear test would mutate the Godzilla
Saurus living there into Godzilla Duritz
can use their wings to fly and can also
sense feelings through microwave
impulses after the Godzilla Saurus was
transported to the Bering Sea the Doris
were left behind to be exposed to the
hydrogen bomb test in 1950 54 which
combined and mutated them into King
Ghidorah number 6 the planet eater the
King Ghidorah of the an eager G
continuity is the latest incarnation of
Ghidorah of the Godzilla franchise and
the first will in the Ray WA era of
films he played a role in Godzilla the
planet era as the main antagonist where
he finally descended onto the planet to
fight Godzilla earth while Ghidorah
retains the classic image of a
three-headed dragon with two wings two
tails and two legs he is very different
from his past incarnations despite
having feet Lee doesn't stand upright
and
position horizontally rather than
vertically the body of Ghidorah looks
like a fiery energy this guitar is also
partially transparent as a result of his
summoning wasn't in possession of his
full true form
King Ghidorah is truly an apex predator
of a universal scale ecosystem which
includes other alien Godzilla's met fees
noted that countless other Godzilla's
along with their planets were devoured
while King Ghidorah this incarnation of
Ghidorah boasts an advanced form of
intangibility which affords him the
advantage of being able to attack while
not being able to be attacked in
response in addition he also bends
reality space and time around himself he
has a length of over 20 kilometers or
more number 7 monster vs. monster 0 in
this version he has an ancient
extraterrestrial tree had a dragon like
Chi Chi who came to earth seeking to
conquer it and terraform it into a state
more of his liking this version stands
at 158 metres tall and weighs over a
hundred and forty thousand tonnes this
is the first incarnation of King
Ghidorah to have the ability to
regenerate his heads his designs also
differs from the classic space monster
in that his necks were narrower and
longer ending up in tree very nicely
designed heads but the main difference
is that he appears to have women like
pair of wings whereby his four limbs are
evolved to let him fly unlike the
previous ones where they just grow out
of his back he Doris intimidation style
is very similar to a king cobra much
like Cobras rise up their heads and
spread their necks general rises up his
stance and spread his wings making
himself appear twice as large as
Godzilla Vidura is able to use his jaws
claws wings and Tails in battle he was
strong enough to lift God's there were
thousands of feet into the air
with very little effort before dropping
him like an atom bomb down to the ground
number eight cretaceous Ghidorah also
known as gran king ghidorah his weaker
and younger fog is cretaceous King
Ghidorah which stands at 40 metres tall
and weighing a bit more than 20,000
tonnes he single-handedly caused the
extinction of the dinosaurs and over
three-fourths of all species on earth
had he
the Cretaceous period potatoes Ghidorah
can spit fireballs from his mouth and
could fly at speed of over Mach 3 he can
also release hurricane winds from his
wings and travel in space by encasing
himself within the media using the
extracted life essences of he consumes
after millions of years Cretaceous King
Ghidorah rose again as Grand King
Ghidorah his design is very similar to
the classical version and possesses very
similar powers this incarnation was also
seen to have easily won over Mothra but
was in the end killed by Armour Mothra
which is a highly evolved form of Mothra
leo confusing right number 9
mecha king ghidorah mecha king ghidorah
is a mechanically modified Ghidorah
created by Toho that first appeared in
the 1991 Godzilla film Godzilla vs. King
Ghidorah mecha King Ghidorah has a
futuristic and mechanical look with his
middle head mechanized as well as his
wings torso and a few other areas
he is considerably more powerful than a
purely organic King Ghidorah make a king
ghidorah flies with an antigravity and a
speed of Mach fo he can fire yellow
gravity beams from his mouth on the left
and right head since it was modified
version of King Ghidorah mega King
Ghidorah can fire a laser triple beam
from the central head he could also
manifest a protective barrier around
himself temporarily rendering him immune
to all energy based damaged by opponents
this version of Ghidorah was created in
the 23rd century and was sent back in
time to the present to defeat Godzilla
he was also the genesis of mecha
godzilla this guy he starts at 150
meters tall and weighs 82 thousand tons
number ten guys a Ghidorah
Kazuki Jorah also known by his previous
form named Master eggs it's the main
kaiju antagonist and overall the
secondary and final antagonist of the
50th anniversary Godzilla film Godzilla
final walls ask Isaac Ghidorah he is
even larger and stronger than he was as
monsta x and possesses the same
abilities as king ghidorah as well as an
energy draining bite his appearance
resembles death Ghidorah in some ways
but also King Ghidorah with a shiny
golden skin
although he possesses wings it is
unlikely that he can fly very much and
only uses them to crush enemies with his
bulk however and the comic series
Godzilla rulers of Earth
Kazuki Dora is able to fly fairly well
Kaiser gaydar is the fourth-tallest
version at 140 meters tall and weighing
a hundred thousand tons behind the
Heisei King Ghidorah and mecha King
Ghidorah both wish appeared in Godzilla
versus King Ghidorah
and the most of us King Ghidorah and
with us we come to the end of the list
of the ten forms versions and all all
types of Ghidorah do you like share
subscribe for more related content and
also hit the notification valve
[Music]